how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and lately it seems like
all anybody can talk about is spider-man
3.
there is a lot happening with spider-man
3 and filming for the movie just started
a couple of days ago which means we're
going to be getting a lot of information
about the movie very soon
including some confirmations of a lot of
things that we've been hearing lately
of course doctor strange and jamie
foxx's electro from the amazing
spider-man 2 are confirmed to be in the
film
and of course there are the reports that
toby maguire and
andrew garfield are returning and
reprising their spider-man
roles so hopefully a lot of this gets
confirmed pretty soon but we actually
had some insane news happened
yesterday a lot is uncertain in 2020
especially when it comes to movies right
now
but sony has revealed to the public that
we are indeed going to get the official
teaser trailer for spider-man 3 in
december
of 2020 this year this is an official
announcement from sony they actually
revealed this yesterday
over the past few days exposing one of
the largest events in latin america in
the cinema industry
held their annual convention virtually
now this was still a
very huge event even though it was
virtual and some of the biggest film
companies around the world
attended disney warner brothers
universal netflix and
sony when it was sony's time for their
panel they treated the audience to some
first looks and behind the scenes
footage for upcoming films such as
monster hunter
connected ghostbusters afterlife and
hotel transylvania 4.
but the highlight was an update on
spider-man
3. the executive marketing director of
sony pictures entertainment in brazil
camilla pacheco
told all the attendees that the film had
already started production and that we
would get our first look
at the film this december 2020.
now as murphy's multiverse.com reported
on their website
she alternated between the words preview
and teaser trailer when discussing the
project
and getting our first look in december
but the bottom line is we're going to
get our first look
and footage in december of this year and
not to mention she also did confirm the
release dates for spider-man 3
morbius and venom let there be carnage
she said
right now as it stands spider-man 3 is
still going to be in december
16th of 2021 morbius will be march 2021
and venom let there be carnage will be
june 2021. now this is super exciting
news we have a lot to look forward to in
spider-man 3 and now we know when the
teaser is coming but let's remember that
it's going to be
just that a teaser if toby maguire
andrew garfield and others are going to
be in this film they're not going to
show us them in the teaser trailer and
probably not in the official trailer
either
but we can definitely figure out what
the plot of the movie is
and who the official main villain of the
movie is going to be
so the great news is that 2020 may
actually end relatively well since we're
getting our very first look at
spider-man 3.
so be sure to subscribe so you stay up
to date on all the latest spider-man 3
and mcu news also don't forget to
subscribe so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win an iron
spider funko pop i'm picking a winner on
monday don't forget to give the video a
like and for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof